we all know added sugar isn't healthy
but is avoiding it worth it we wanted to
find out so we asked three sugar addicts
to change their diets for a month to see
what happens when you give up sugar for
breakfast I usually have like a
starburst I'm interested in this
challenge because I started working in
office jobs
I went from 125 to 165 so should I not
be drinking this thing I feel bad for
everyone in my life because it it is it
does feel like my mood a lot of the time
is directly tied to my diet I'll get
like stressed out I got a headache sip a
ton of sugar I'm 27 I think it's time to
start eating like an adult and not like
a 16 year old
it's just it's just been an emotional
roller coaster of a week what do I drink
to get a caffeine soda I don't want to
drink black coffee like black coffee
straight it's shitty super bowl sucks
cuz I just got to sit there and eat like
corn chips that tasted really crappy and
then today we're his free cupcake hey
this sucks but to Disneyland yesterday
everyone was eating tasty treats I
couldn't have any of these tasty treats
so I had a pickle I feel that like
weirdo cuz I'm in the grocery store like
looking at the back of everything to see
what's in it and I never wanted to be
that guy and that guy any positive
changes
um I don't know not really oh I hope
it's worth it so last week was really
bad but this week I'm kind of used to it
and actually slipped up and grabbed a
can of coke and drank it last night
I drank soda to try to stay awake those
didn't work
I feel like junk this morning I I have
been down a bit lost a few pounds I feel
like I'm more positive I feel like my
energy levels are more level and I don't
have these like low this is actually not
that bad I feel like I don't know I feel
like I could do this I feel like I feel
like I can actually stop eating so much
sugar
I lost five pounds that's crazy
five pounds of fat according to the body
contest so yeah I feel pretty good about
the you know the direct result I
actually can confidently say I don't
miss sugar that much crazy mind-blowing
life-changing yes all of the above
planning my meals I'm like using all
fresh ingredients something about this
diet is it's making eight cook again
which I haven't done an embarrassingly
long time kind of like looking at what
you put in your body look in the back
the ingredients for just being conscious
of it was huge didn't like this third
week I was like wow like I'm like much
I'm like happy I'm really happy right
now and I feel calm and not stressed out
I drink more water now mm-hmm hi I'm
glad I did it that's all for the better
yeah I don't want that diabetes my dad's
got it I want to get that yeah at the
beginning I was like I can't wait till
the month is over so that I can go back
and eat all the sugar that I'm missing
and now I don't even think I'm gonna do
that I think I'm gonna stick with it for
a little bit longer Who am I Who am I am
I an adult now